Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in a learning disability service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the story has reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good
interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. Psychology loves talking about inclusion. That is, of course, until a blind person arrives at interview or on placement with a guide dog in tow and they're ready to work or ready to try out for the role. And then suddenly everyone realizes just how inaccessible our systems really are. In this episode, I'm chatting with Sky about what it actually takes to train as a psychologist, when the world wasn't necessarily designed with you in mind.
We hope you find it really helpful. If you do, please like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am joined here by Sky Hewitt. Welcome along, Sky. Hi, thank you for having me. Thank you for your, you know, your willingness to talk with us so openly. And we were talking just before we started about the fact that you are now a first-year trainee clinical psychologist.
And moreover than that, you know, what's even more impressive because that is an achievement in itself is that you're also registered blind and you have a guide dog called Derek. Could you tell us a little bit about your journey to being a trainee if that's OK, Sky? Yeah, absolutely. So I suppose I started working out that I wanted to study psychology or become a psychologist whilst I was doing my A levels as a lot of us sort of do. And I ended up doing an integrated master's degree. So sort of an undergraduate four year master's degree in psychology. And I really enjoyed that. And then I decided to apply for a post. postgraduate master's degree in clinical neuroscience because I really enjoyed my neuroscience modules and I thought let's go and study something a bit different, especially because I found out about a really amazing opportunity through the Snowden Trust who offer scholarships for disabled students and grants and different things. So I sort of took my shot at that and was lucky enough to get one. So I did that. And then I became an AP.
for a year and applied for the Declin, got a few interviews, got a couple of offers and sort of here I am and so it's been a whirlwind of different things and changes and yeah. Thank you so much and yeah like I said we did have a chat before we hit record as well and I feel like you might have a touch of imposter syndrome about you Sky but yeah that's that's healthy I would say but it doesn't mean that you're not ready to be doing what you're doing. You know, you clearly have learned your trade and evidence that you are qualified to be where you are at. But also, I think, you know, when you've had adverse experiences, it kind of helps you develop that bit quicker than people who often don't. And when you're having to be, you know, advocating for yourself
constantly and relentlessly, I think it drags you up a bit quicker. Do you agree with you? I do. I think especially when I do, I don't know, when I compare myself to my peers who are my age or my colleagues who are a little bit older than me, you know, even as an AP and my colleagues who were maybe in their 30s and we'd talk about what they were doing at my age versus what I'm doing. And yeah, I think maybe I have just had to grow up quite quick and get used to communicating in different ways quite quickly. And yeah, so I'd agree with. that for sure and is it okay for me to say how old you are sky yeah yeah I'm 24 perfect so you will be qualified long before you're 30 so yeah like you
know well done to you and I hope that you really enjoy training it's a real time of transformation and you get to learn from people some of whom you will like their approach some of whom you won't and you just get to keep the bits that you do like so I do hope that you enjoy training Could you tell us if it's okay a little bit about your, about the level of your visual impairment? Yeah, so as we sort of said, I'm registered blind, but that means I still have a little bit of vision that I can use. So I've always been registered blind. I was born with glaucoma and have had lots of different surgeries and subsequent sort of problems with my eyes growing up.
I've always had a bit of vision that's slowly gotten worse. And now I can still sort of read some very large text and see a few things and people to make out who people are here and there. But yeah, registered blind. Thank you. And yeah, I would love this episode to be used as inspiration for people that might have their own visual impairments to think, oh, I didn't realize psychology was maybe an option for me. Or maybe someone's told them, this isn't an option for you. And so they've been discouraged by that. So maybe we can get them early enough in their education that they're like, oh, nice.
Okay, let me explore. Or maybe we can encourage people to kind of retrain or think about what steps they might need to do. But also, we really want this episode to be used by people who do not have visual impairments to think about, I don't know, language that might be okay or not okay, that might be preferred or not preferred. or not preferred, and for learning about the experience of people with visual impairments to inform their practice, make them curious, and maybe even think of some ideas that they might not know already. And even before we hit record, we spoke about a couple of things and you were like, oh, I don't really love about that. So we will cover some of that, but this is
going to be a kind of a multi-purpose episode is the plan. But yeah, like really empowering is what we want to, we want to empower anyone listening for any reason. That's the plan anyway. Could you tell us a little bit, if it feels okay, you don't need to single anyone out? Have you experienced any stigma or kind of dissuasion for the idea of going on to become a qualified clinical psychologist? Yeah, it's somewhat mixed. I feel like in the visual impairment world, there are a lot of counsellors and a lot of therapists in different ways but I think when it comes to pursuing clinical psychology specifically there's suddenly a bit more stigma and barriers I guess and I think for me it did start at undergrad specifically and just people not really knowing if I could do it or if it would be possible. if it was reasonable for me to have those aspirations. But then more specifically, I have had a very distinct experience
when interviewing for AP positions, assistant psychologist positions, where one of my interviews, I just don't, I think it was a significant lack of awareness, but they pretty much said to me, if they knew that I was blind, they wouldn't have invited me to interview. They didn't think I could do the job because of different things. like they used a lot of paper forms or they didn't understand why Derek, my guide dog, was
there. So that was quite a jarring experience. Fortunately, I had another assistant psychologist interview that went very well and I ended up working with them and it was an absolutely incredible team. So very different experiences. But yeah, I didn't expect it, but it definitely happened and yeah I'm sorry to hear that but isn't it isn't it illegal for for them to say that to you yes yes I think in the moment I was still in that mode of you know you're coming to this panel interview you're trying to impress you're trying to get a job and I and I was still very much trying to almost prove to them well you know we can do this we can do this and I can do the job and it wasn't until I came away and thought about it
where I then suddenly was reflecting on how not okay that experience was. Interestingly, I did get offered that position but then I turned it down and accepted the other one. So yeah, it was an interesting experience, but you're right it is illegal to do that. Yeah, I think there's very much something about the way people make you feel I've been in a position where I've been offered jobs and hadn't liked the process.
and then decided to say no. And I think that's, you know, that's really living up to your own values and knowing that you're worthwhile and you should be treated with dignity and respect. I do know of another qualified psych, a health psychologist who is blind and has a going dog. And so I've learned a little bit through him about where his dog can go and where his dog can't go.
So could you eliminate our audience about what I might mean there, Sky? Yeah. So this is actually quite relevant for me as well with my AP position because I was in a clinical health psychology team, which often we were then going and working in the hospital. So, yeah, wild guide dogs legally have access to pretty much everywhere. There are a few exceptions. So that would be places where there are a strict sort of infection control sorts of settings.
I'm thinking ICU because part of my work as an AP was on an ICU psychology research project. So there are certain areas in hospitals and outside of the psychology world, zoos and things can decline service dogs because they have to think about their own animal welfare. But yeah, on the large scale guide dogs should legally be allowed. pretty much everywhere bar a few exceptions yeah and i think some of the arguments that um that the psychologist i'm thinking of is it's actually air bn bs and hotels and and kind of trains and taxes and you're not allowed to to say no in those circumstances is that right sky that's correct there are like for all of those examples um i'm thinking about air bn bs and taxis There are a few procedures that people can go through if they do have a significant allergy.
But they can't just say, I have an allergy. You can't bring your guide dog. They have to have formal paperwork and things that say that. So unfortunately, it's very common. I've had access refusals pretty much everywhere. It's in different types of settings. Airbnb, taxis, shops, restaurants. And it's, yeah, it's disappointing every single time.
And it's, you know, constantly reminding people. of the law and and you know why it's so important to allow a service still in yeah absolutely it's so important we we kind of raise this narrative really and reinforce it and actually i think derrick could be a real strength and a real asset therapeutically so i understand he's not a therapy dog he's not a trained therapy dog he's a he's a what's he what is his name what's his is an assistant's dog isn't he yeah assistant's dog or service dog but then under that umbrella he's my guide dog so yeah yeah okay um but you know for i think for a variety of clients i've worked with in the past having a dog in the room would have
been really beneficial um however you know sometimes i've done some dog phobia at work and you know depending on what breed derrick is that might have felt not that helpful um so yeah like Do clients ever know in advance that you are going to be visually impaired or do they rock up on day one and then it's like, oh, here's Derek, his sky? So individual clients, I'm thinking about recently where I've booked some people in, I do give them the warning. I say, just to let you know I have a service dog, like, is that okay? Do you have any thoughts about that, like about there being a dog in the room? I don't necessarily disclose right away on the phone call that I'm blind and he's a guide dog but I say I have a service dog and then when we meet I'll be able to talk more about what it might mean having a blind therapist but historically there are a few examples maybe if I'm going into a group setting in a hospital where I might not tell them in advance but that's more of like a professional group setting but but yeah one to one I like to give people that bit of warning because you're right people could
have all sorts of previous experiences with dogs and Derek is a big dog he's half German shepherd half golden retriever so yeah you just don't know how that might impact on the space and I mean it could be very positive for a lot of people just having the dog there I know for me he's a massive icebreaker you know outside of work as well just socially and is is a comforting presence for a lot of people, but you just never know how people are going to feel about it. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, Derek the icebreaker. He does sound like a big dog.
I think in one of our thumbnails on YouTube, I think we've got at least one photo of Derek. So if anyone wants to check Derek out with Sky, they absolutely can. Can we have a little bit of a chat about kind of how we should refer to somebody with a visual impairment? So just before we hit record, we were talking about actually, you know, over the most recent years, autistic people now like to be identity first. Is it okay to call you a blind person or a person with visual impairments or a visually impaired person? Like, I appreciate this might be specific to you, but could you maybe explain how we would have that conversation with somebody and what your preference is? Yeah, so it is very individual. I think the different charities I've worked with and different people I know all have different preferences. So it is really important to ask the person that you're speaking to how they would prefer to be spoken about. For me, I think I prefer identity first language, sort of saying I like to describe myself as a blind person or often I'll say I'm registered blind just because people. have this misconception that if I say I'm blind it means I can see absolutely
nothing and that's not the case so that I often try and it's hard isn't it I try and balance my language to almost make sure people understand what I mean but also advocating for a broader understanding of what the words mean as well but yeah I I don't have enormous strong feelings either way but I I tend to lean towards identity first language Thank you. So maybe almost like a little bit of an imposter syndrome there about calling yourself blind because you've got some usable vision. But yeah, people's, people's understanding of the term blind is literally that there'd be nothing. And when I was working in the community
with people with physical disabilities, I very quickly learned that you can have a registration as blind, but actually still be able to even read some text, as you said, that you can. But yeah, you are very much, is it okay to see disadvantaged compared to people with 2020 vision? Is that, is that all right? That's appropriate to say. Yeah, I'd say so. You know, I have a disability. I'm a disabled person. There are various things that I'm disadvantaged by.
I do think often about like the social model of disability and how it is the environment and the systems that cause most of the problems. You know, I can do a lot of things completely independently and work things out for myself as long as the environment and the systems are set up in a suitable way. So, yeah, whilst my vision puts me at a disadvantage in some ways, I would also say the systems are often more of the problem. Yeah, and that really nicely segues us into what was going to be in the next area for conversation, which is kind of the tools that help you to kind of engage. engage fully with the tasks that you need to do.
Could you give us a little bit of an overview of the things that really support you to thrive optimally at work and maybe at home as well? Yeah, I mean, practically I rely on a lot of technology. So a lot of accessibility software, large screens, high contrast, magnification, voice over occasionally when I need to use that. I benefit from a lot of sort of extra time for orientation and mobility for myself, but also for Derek.
You know, he has to learn new routes and it can be tricky making sure his training is up to par and he's meeting my needs if I'm not given enough time to do all of that. It's interesting. I'm, I feel like, and I'm sure a lot of disabled people will relate to this, we get very good at problem solving and just working things out and to an extent getting by. And so I think the thing that's most impactful, for me at least, is just having really direct contact with course tutors, supervisors, really open communication because it's very hard to just have cut and dry solutions to things and one thing might work one day and not the next or for one system and not the other. and it's so granular and situation-specific. So having that regular contact just to troubleshoot and discuss and even just think about how you're feeling about all of it because it's also exhausting. I really don't want to understate how time-consuming being disabled is
and the administrative burden, the way it takes so much energy and thinking just to sort of do everything that everyone else is doing. So yeah. Thanks, Sky. And like if, you know, if you were my trainee, I would have quite a steep learning curve to be able to think about how to teach you
to do the things that I would see as kind of quite, the processes that I would want you to have an understanding of. Like, could we almost do like a little bit of a, this is how we would get around that or we would do this differently? So, for example, if you were joining me for an initial assessment, And I would use my remarkable tablet and I would usually, or paper, you know, in old school days, I would usually sort of draw a family tree to get an understanding systemically of that person and their relationships. And I would usually jot down sort of histories about, you know, presenting problems or significant bits and pieces of their life.
And maybe, you know, some physical health bits and their previous history with kind of mental health services and whether. there were any medication. I do not feel I would be able to accurately hold all of that in my mind for an initial assessment, especially if I then needed to go away and write a report. So could you guide us through how you would help me as a potential supervisor to help you thrive optimally in that sort of setting? Yeah. So, I mean, these are conversations I've been having a lot recently as well anyway and for me it's because I am able to handwrite something sort of on my iPad. I know you mentioned the remarkable tablet, but I'm able to do some of that, you know, handwrite some notes and make sure it's just very big and high contrast and then I can have
a closer look later and type things up or the flip of that I could be sort of touch typing and then review that later. I do also. it whilst yes it is hard to remember I would say a lot of blind people do have incredibly good memories and I do know some people mostly will rely on their memory in sessions that is not me yet I might get there at some point but obviously I'm holding a lot in mind about how to structure assessments and formulations and different things so for me it's a lot of still handwriting notes just in an inaccessible way to me and yeah i imagine it's going to change a lot as i go through training as well but that's the current plan yeah and actually when i was a first year trainee my first placement my placement supervisor encouraged me to to record so audio record all sessions so that we could then listen back to them in supervision but um that is a whole other conversation of cringe but um i guess that might be something that would help you to then listen back to type your reports for example
Is that something that you've explored in the past? Yeah, so it definitely will be the plan to record as many sessions as I can. I mean, that's recommended to all of the cohort just for the course requirements and professional development and things. But for me especially, that will be the plan to hopefully record as many as many as I can. Great. And do you read Braille? I can. I don't, just because I'm a very slow. braille reader but yes I can okay and is that taught you know often to people with sight impairments or is it hit and missed does it depend on what kind of school
you went to for example it I I would like to think that any severely visually impaired children are being taught Braille and touch typing that was my experience as much as I didn't enjoy it when I was was little. I think it felt really unnecessary when I was younger, but my understanding is it is or should be offered to every severely visually impaired child, yeah, in school. Okay, but for whatever reason, it's just never really, it's never really resonated with you or you've kind of find other ways around it or because you've got some sight, maybe you haven't had the pressure to really, you know, become very speedy with that. Yeah.
I think it's always been because I had enough sight to not have to rely on those things. I never felt as motivated to learn and get really good at it. And then a big discussion about Braille at the moment is how technology is so advanced that do we even need Braille? The argument is we do and Braille allows especially completely blind children to learn a lot more about literacy and things. So I know a lot of people don't learn Braille at all because technology is so advanced now as well. Yeah, thank you. And speaking about technology, I'm aware that the meta AI glasses can
potentially revolutionise kind of what it is like to be someone with a visual impairment or registered blind, because as I understand it, when you wear a pair of them, you can ask it to tell you what it's looking at or it will just read kind of information on screen for you when you look at it. At the moment, I think you couldn't walk down the street and it wouldn't automatically say there's a black dog to your left watch out there's a red brick wall straight in front of you but if you said if there is anything to my left is there anything straight in front of me it would tell you but you can see that over time it will be refined so that it can kind of give you more a running narrative um is there any other technology like do you use the be my eyes app
or are there any other kind of tech things that we could be be mindful of I do use my phone a lot and sort of the built-in features, even just the camera, you know, being able to take pictures of things, zoom into things, read menus and signs by using the camera. I do use AI quite a lot to speed up different things that I do just because they can take a bit longer or take a bit of extra eye strain. So AI is really helpful. I did also used to have a Braille smartwatch, which was an incredibly interesting piece of tech that I think is currently discontinued, but they will be revamping it hopefully in the future because I would be keen to get a new one. And that was really useful because I could very subtly check the time. And it's one of those things, especially when I think about structuring therapy sessions and
keeping to time how I can subtly check the time without it being really obvious and that was really great because it did connect to my phone and it would pop up in braille and it would also like read me my text messages and things like that with the braille so I could just silently read those rather than having anything talking to me or you know an enormous clock that I'm having to bring right to my face so yeah there are there are some really interesting pieces of tech in the sort of visual impairment disability space, I think the meta glasses are a really nice example of where that technology is becoming more universal to everybody and there's like a universal piece of tech that also really benefits disabled people. But there is a whole other world of technology that
just people don't really know about just because it's generally geared towards a specific group of people. I have to say I don't think I'd ever considered how some someone with visual impairment knows the time. And I'm sorry that I hadn't considered that. I think some of the people I worked with in the past wore a watch. But yeah, would perhaps bring it right to their faces. But the idea of a braille watch for somebody that wants to be discreet or, yeah, because you're thinking, how long have we got left of this session and you have to do that?
Or if you're thinking, you know, you're going on a bit, my friend. And we haven't really got time for this. You want to have a quick look at your watch or a quick connection with the time, don't you? rather than nefters really being that explicit. So, yeah, I do hope that they're able to kind of reissue that Braille watch because that does sound like a really essential kind of leveller, actually. But, you know, like you said, it's not necessarily that we're asking you to have special adaptations. It's that actually we're waiting for society to become more inclusive.
And then people who have got OK vision might then also really use that and benefit from that as well. for example, Audible. I love listening to audio books. So I will usually listen to business books on Audible, whereas when I'm snuggled down in bed trying to get ready to go to sleep, I prefer fiction in my hands. But yeah, like loads of people have learned amazing things or just listen to pleasure for Audible and audiobooks, haven't they? Like, are you much of an audio listener to things? I do love Audible. I have a lot. a lot of books on there that are sort of on my to be listened to list um i've not had a lot of time since starting the course but yeah i i do love audible i i used to read
physical books as a teenager very very close to my face um and then i sort of transition to my ipad and i'd have the text really really big and really high contrast and i can still do that but it's very taxing um so audiobooks are just brilliant for that and it is is a nice example of just how universal design and accessibility just works for a lot of people that way. Yeah, it really does. And if it's okay, could you tell us a bit about whether your eyes cause you discomfort? So you said you might get eye strain. Are you having to, you know, apply drops? Are you having to have any time off? Are you having to have shorter days to be mindful of your eyesight? How does the actual physical care of your eyes work? So I used to have a lot of
pain. And then I had some surgery, which has resolved a lot of that. So I wouldn't necessarily say I deal with a lot of eye pain anymore, which is really great because that was very, very hard at university. During my undergrad, I missed a lot of lectures and had to catch up online and things. But I suppose one of the reasonable adjustments that I have now in work is disability related leave or special leave to attend specifically like my eye hospital recently I had a bit of a eye scare where we weren't sure if I was having a retinal detachment and I had to go to hospital quite a lot in the space of a week and luckily the staff and the course have all been incredibly supportive and understanding but yeah it's just another thing that I have to think
about how I structure my days and my weeks and making sure that things like lighting are suitable and that I can navigate a space and that Derek's needs are met and I can get him water and take him outside when I need to. There's just lots of thinking about the practicalities and travelling to and from placement and teaching and yeah, there's a lot to think about. And when you're on a placement day, I presume you have to take, do you take food for Derek or is he a dog that only eats at morning and night? Like, how does that work practically? So he just has breakfast and dinner.
And then throughout the day, as I believe most service dogs do, I have a treat pouch on me and he'll get different treats because we're sort of constantly training. But yeah, so luckily I don't really have to think about bringing any food unless I was doing a late shift. say, for example, if I was going to work 12 till 8 instead, then I'd probably bring his dinner and give it to him there. But I do have to think about, you know, setting up a little space for him with his bed and his water bowl and a toy and things like that.
So one placement, you'd have an extra bed and you'd leave that placement, I guess, rather than kind of having this big rucksack with Derek's things and your things and everything. You have many, many beds for Derek that are Derek approved and he's a fan of. that seems important absolutely um could you tell us before we finish what what is glaucoma in case people aren't aware oh you're going to test me here it's one of those things that i've just sort of grown up being being told about and think about did anyone ever really teach me but um basically it means that i have high pressure in my eyes so the sort of the fluid inside my eyes builds up and doesn't release how it should, which can put pressure on the optic nerve at the
back of the eye, which then causes permanent damage and vision loss. And I know generally it's considered to be something that affects older people later in life, but it can also be inherited or you can be born with it. They're not entirely sure on the causes, but it can also be very aggressive when you're born with it and then it can lead to a lot of secondary eye conditions as well because of all the drops and the surgeries um yeah thank you that seems really important that we have an understanding of what that is but it sounds like you know you've you've had to endure a lot since since you were born and um your parents must have really had to work hard to advocate for you and your needs as a as a as a blind baby um
And a blind, I cannot imagine trying to parent my children when they were toddlers if they hadn't had, you know, lots of usable vision. Like it feels dangerous enough with kids with more vision. Like did they, how did they, do you know much about how they did that practically? Yeah. So my mum raised me and my sister and my sister's fully cited. But I know that it was a struggle. I was always in pain. I had to be, I could never lay down because I was in lots of pain.
And I had to have blankets over the push chair because the sun was too bright. I remember having, even into like sort of middle childhood blankets over lamps and things because things were too bright. As far as my vision, I was a very confident child and I think I could see enough that I could get by. And I'm sure my mom had her worries here and there about me like running down the hill and into something. But generally I think, you know, she encouraged me to just explore the world and climb trees and be as adventurous as I could. She didn't want me to not do things. You know, doctors said to her that I would never ride a bike.
And she sort of took that as a challenge. Like, yes, she will ride a bike. So, yeah, I think it was more so the pain and just, you know, she had to pin me down to do eyedrops and things. which I must have been brutal for her to do yeah yeah it I well my heart goes out to her but also to you being a little distress baby not wanting these eyedrops and finding everything so painful like it's it's not been easy for you do you still do sport do you still do exercise are you kind of you know what what are you up to for your for your hobbies um I definitely don't do as much active stuff as I'd like um I've really
I've recently been in touch with a local aerial fitness studio trying to see if I can try some of that because that sort of piques my interest, just to get a bit more active and try something new. I love learning new things, so we'll see how that goes. But more generally, I love travelling. My fiancé and I went interrailing for a couple of months around Europe, which is a whole other world of thinking about how you do that when you're disabled. But yeah, I just love going out and exploring and trying new things. Amazing. I'm thinking that Derek would much prefer the trains than the aerial hoops. I'm not sure we're going to be getting Derek on the ribbons any time soon. Thank you so much for your time. Is there anything you think is really important that we share with the audience before we finish Sky? I think just to say how valuable and enriching disabled voices are, not just in clinical psychology, but just broadly, I think you know, society's attitudes are improving, but it's still generally, I think often disabled
people are overlooked and just disability as a minority is overlooked. You know, it's the only minority group that anybody can join at any point. You know, you're just an illness or an accident away. And I think it's important to be to be mindful of that and how we make the world more accessible and inclusive and value the contributions that disabled people bring because we are, you know, generalising but we're great problem solvers we're incredibly ambitious i think often to our own detriment because we're trying to overcompensate but yeah we have a lot to bring um so yeah but also it's very hard like acknowledging that is important i don't want to make this too in like like it's an inspirational story because it's it's hard it's very hard advocating for yourself all the time
and pushing the boundaries all the time but it's it's doable and enjoyable do you enjoy what you do Yes, I love it. I absolutely love it. And, yeah, I mean, based off the fact I did two masters, I loved university and I'm loving the Declan course so far. So yeah. Amazing. Long may that last. And thank you for helping myself, but also our audience, you know, really think about this and, you know, empower people to kind of pursue what is a bit of them really, regardless of kind of what they might have been told about themselves or what they might believe about themselves as being possible or impossible. Thank you again so much for your time and do stay in touch, Sky. Thank you so much for having me. It's been great. Oh, brilliant. Thank you so
much for Sky's time. And to you if you are listening or watching this as someone who is not visually impaired, what I would say is that you likely will make mistakes. You likely will make faux paths, just as I finished my call with Sky, I said, lovely to see you, and then we're hung up. And afterwards, I sort of caught myself just as I was clicking the, oh, my watch is telling me the time. That's not helpful. I, yeah, just as I was clicking the end button, I sort of realized what I'd said. And I think we have to forgive ourselves, but also if that was in a client session, I would likely say, I'm really sorry, at the end of our session last time, I realized I did say lovely to see you because it was but I appreciate that might not be a phrase that feels particularly
inclusive yeah this is like I don't know the way that I am pleasant with people and it was lovely to see her you know um we can we can second guess ourselves as well but yes that was my own little in process moment um I hope you've found this helpful if you have why not at like subscribe, drop a comment, maybe even drop a question in. If you've got any questions about what it's like to navigate the world as a visually impaired person, we can absolutely get Sky answering some of those. Please do subscribe or follow for more. If you're on Spotify, you can drop any questions in there as well. By the time this episode comes out, there will also be the opportunity for subscriber only content, which will be available for a small
fee, which is to help me to be able to continue to bring you really high quality, great episodes. And that is going to be available from YouTube and from Spotify and I hope from Apple Podcasts as well. So do check that out. And there's a chance to get some kind of behind the scene staff, some more insightful, kind of reflective pieces from me, thinking about how I begin to plan and put together things. Yeah. And actually, even if you're listening to this as a qualified member of staff or someone that just passionately believe psychologists and people working in psychology are to be invested in, and you might consider subscribing just for that content so that you can help to support my creator cost to keep me being able to do this
for longer. Thank you so much for anybody who's already doing that by the time this goes live. I would love your feedback as well. In the episode, Sky and I briefly touched on the Snowden Trust and it was the Snowden Trust that offered a scholarship to Sky so she was able to do her second masters. If you are disabled and interested in accessing education, please do do check out their website, which is snowdon trust.org. Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences.
People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.